kim kardashian is a west no more and
it's instagram official
oh my god
on thursday the 41 year old reality star
officially removed her married last name
from instagram just one day after the
courts granted her petition to be
declared legally single and legally a
kardashian again amid her divorce
proceedings with kanye west
it's a different experience for sure but
this does not mean her divorce is final
in a nutshell kim's marital status will
now be single while she continues to
work out a divorce settlement with a 44
year old rapper at the end of the day
life is about being happy the judge made
the ruling wednesday morning in court
where the kkw beauty founder also gave a
short testimony via zoom and answered a
few questions about how the former
couple's four children north saint
chicago and psalm are doing amid the
split kim told the court everyone is
doing okay and when asked if she's
showering her kids with affection she
replied absolutely i do have a family
that i have to just be positive and get
it together for the following day kim
made her first public appearance since
the court declared her single attending
a revolve event in la on thursday that's
the skim's founder looking biker chic in
a head-to-toe black leather balenciaga
ensemble complete with a black padded
jacket matching leggings and gloves
black pointy heels and a small black bag
i love that energy in my life of course
this all comes after a rocky february
which saw yay hurl a series of
accusations at kim on instagram
including that she didn't provide the
address for their daughter chicago's
birthday party put security on him when
he was playing with his son had him take
a drug test after the party and that
their eldest daughter north is on tick
tock against his wishes
[Music]
a source told e.t back in january that
kim was upset by kanye's antics which
also included several social media posts
trashing kim's new beau pete davidson
and just a few hours after the judge's
ruling came down the grammy winner
released a disturbing music video for
his track easy which shows yay
kidnapping a claymation figure of pete
than burying him in the ground
the cameras watch the kids i stop taking
the credits
next door
this next one
[Music]
the video ends with a reference to skeet
yea's go-to nickname for the comedian a
title card reads everyone lived happily
ever after then except you know who with
the name skeet crossed out and finally
jk he's fine just something for my heart
now a source tells e.t kim is upset
because pete has been nothing but kind
and continues to be brought into kanye's
drama and doesn't deserve it i'm just
rolling with it the source adds quote
the couple is very happy and hopefully
over time kanye will come to terms that
kim being happy is all that matters
[Music]
you